2020.
"THE STORY" CONTINUES AND I WILL
SEE YOU AGAIN TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE CORONAVIRUS IS NOW IN EVERY
AMERICAN STATE AND HAS KILLED
MORE THAN 100 PEOPLE HERE SO
FAR.
THE NUMBER, OF COURSE, WILL
RISE.
IN ITALY, THE VIRUS KILLED
ALMOST 500 PEOPLE TODAY.
NOBODY IS INVULNERABLE TO IT.
JUST AN HOUR AGO, A CONGRESSMAN
IN FLORIDA BECAME THE FIRST
FEDERAL LAWMAKER CONFIRMED TO
HAVE THE VIRUS.
WE WILL BE COVERING EVERY ASPECT
OF THIS PANDEMIC THIS OUR PURELY
ECONOMIC EFFECT, THE EFFECT ON
SOCIETY, THE ROLE OF CHINA AND
ALL OF THIS, WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANT.
WE WILL ALSO INTERVIEW WITH A
PERSON RECOVERING FROM THE VIRUS
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
YOU WILL HEAR THAT.
BEFORE THAT, AS WE HAVE EVERY
NIGHT, WE WANT TO OPEN WITH A
BIG PICTURE LOOK AT THE CURRENT
STATE OF CORONAVIRUS, AND WHO
BETTER THAN DR. ANTHONY FAUCI,
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY AND
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
DR. FAUCI JOINS US ON.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE
ADMINISTRATION, HAS SPENT AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
RESPONDING, AND IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY ARE POURING ALL OF THEIR
ENERGY AND ALL OF THEIR EFFORTS
INTO PROTECTING THE COUNTRY FROM
THE SPIRIT AS OF NOW.
IS IT WORKING, DO YOU THINK?
>> I’M CERTAIN IT’S HAVING AN
IMPACT.
IT’S NOT ABLE TO BE MEASURED
PRECISELY, BECAUSE YOU ARE TWO
THINGS GOING ON AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU HAVE AN ESCALATION OF THE
INFECTIONS, AND YOU HAVE ALL OF
THE THINGS WE’VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT AND DOING OVER THE PAST
FEW DAYS THAT IS BLUNTING THAT,
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THESE TWO
DYNAMIC THINGS GOING ON WITH THE
SAME TIME, YOU CAN’T
QUANTITATIVELY SAY HOW MUCH IS
HAVING AN EFFECT.
BUT FOR ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN, IT’S
WHEN YOU DO THE KIND OF
MITIGATION APPROACHES THAT ARE
BEING DONE RIGHT NOW, AND ALL OF
THE OTHER EFFORT THAT’S BEEN
GOING IN RIGHT NOW, CERTAINLY
IT’S HAVING AN EFFECT.
HOWEVER, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
TOMORROW, AS YOU JUST MENTIONED
NOW, THERE WILL BE MORE CASES,
AND THERE WILL CONTINUE TO GO UP
THAT DOESN’T MEAN WHAT WE ARE
DOING IS NOT HAVING AN IMPORTANT
EFFECT.
>> Tucker: WHERE ARE WE, CAN
YOU ESTIMATE, AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS?
>> WHEN YOU SAY THE DEVELOPMENT,
YOU MEAN THE EVOLUTION OF THE
OUTBREAK, TUCKER?
>> Tucker: THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THE EVOLUTION OF THE OUTBREAK OF
CORONAVIRUS IN THE U.S.
>> IT IS STILL IN THE ESCALATION
PHASE, THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
YOU TAKE A LOOK -- IT’S UNEVEN.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT GOT HIT EARLY AND
HAD COMMUNITIES SPREAD, LIKE IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
NEW YORK, RIGHT NOW, IS HAVING A
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT PROBLEM.
THAT IS THE WAY YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE IT OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE NOT A
HOMOGENEOUS EVOLUTION OF IT.
IT’S GOING TO BE THIS WAY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE REAL NUMBER IS?
IS IT KNOWABLE OR GUESSABLE?
IS IT WORTH GUESSING, OF
INFECTIONS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT’S NOT WORTH
GUESSING, TUCKER.
CERTAINLY, AS YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
HAVE AN EVOLUTION OF AN
OUTBREAK, AND HISTORICALLY, THIS
IS TRUE FOR EVERY OUTBREAK,
PARTICULARLY ONES OF DISEASES
THAT WE’VE NEVER HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH BEFORE.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY MORE PEOPLE
OUT THERE, PROBABLY MANY MORE
PEOPLE, WHO ARE INFECTED, WHO
HAVE NOT YET COME TO OUR
ATTENTION.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE MAJOR EXPANSION OF TESTING
IS GOING TO GIVE US A BETTER
IDEA OF THAT.
BUT I THINK IT IS FOLLY TO TRY
TO PUT A NUMBER ON IT WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS IN MOTION
AND DYNAMICALLY MOVING.
>> Tucker: THAT SOUNDS RIGHT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT AROSE TODAY.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
SUGGESTING PEOPLE NOT USE
IBUPROFEN, THAT WILL BE
BRAND-NAME ADVIL.
AND FRENCH RESEARCHERS ARE
SAYING THE SAME, SUGGESTING IT
MIGHT EXACERBATE THE DISEASE,
ITS PROGRESSION TO THE LUNGS.
IS THAT GOOD GUIDANCE, DO YOU
THINK?
DO YOU THINK THAT IS TRUE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE IS NO
REAL, SCIENTIFIC DATA, TUCKER,
THAT TELLS YOU THAT THAT IS A
FACT, OR EVIDENCE-BASED.
I THINK WHAT THEY ARE REFERRING
TO IS THEY WANT TO BE THE BETTER
PART OF REALLY BEING CAUTIOUS,
BECAUSE THERE IS A SYNDROME THAT
IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE USE OF
ASPIRIN IN CHILDREN WITH
INFLUENZA THAT GIVES THEM A
NEUROLOGICAL SYNDROME, AND I
BELIEVE WHAT THEY ARE
THINKING, SINCE THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP OBVIOUSLY BETWEEN
NONSTEROIDAL’S AND ASPIRIN,
MAYBE THERE WILL BE SOME HARM,
BUT THERE IS NO REAL STUDY THAT
DEFINITIVELY PROVES THAT BUT
THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU TAKE IT?
>> WHAT I TAKE IT?
WHEN I GET A FEVER OR AN EIGHT,
I TAKE TYLENOL, BUT I’VE BEEN
DOING THAT ALL MY LIFE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
THAT’S GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME.